while most plants may be able to skate
by in life by lounging in the dirt and
photosynthesizing when zombies are on
your lawn in plants vs. zombies garden
warfare even the toughest tubers need
some strategy get your roots down into
these tips and use them to turn your
fetid foes into heaps of sweet sweet
compost the plants for the most part are
all about keeping the zombies at a
distance no class embodies this more
than the king of long range PBZ
firepower the cactus those red needles
sting badly worse if you tagged the
zombie in its head and it's your job to
watch over the main lanes of ingress to
protect your garden and shoot down any
zombie head drones that hover your way
keep in mind that each of your shots has
a tracer though so any zombie with half
a brain will know where to find you
set up obstacles for would-be flankers
by laying down some tall mutts and
dropping a potato mine behind them
hopefully your enemies will shamble over
the barrier and blow themselves to
chunky bits this is also a great move to
pull if you're fleeing zombies as well
dropping mines barriers and more Minds
to make the pursuit perilous maximizing
your abilities is key to pvz victory so
let no mind go unlaid oh and don't
forget about that hideous garlic drone
that you have in your prickly pockets it
goes down easily so avoid drawing direct
attention and fire at enemies that are
already engaged with fighting your
allies if you wait a few seconds before
flying into the fray your airstrike
ability will be ready just in time for
you to reign hot corn death upon the
zombie menace
the peashooter is the other offensive
powerhouse in the plant splatoon as the
main pea shot boasts good distance
accuracy and splash damage with a
sunflower at your back you're one of the
deadliest Vanquishers on the block
especially with well times chili bomb
those big red beans stick out pretty
prominently so take advantage of
distracted groups or slowed zombies for
easy victims or use your hyper to scoot
around the flank and surprise your
rotten foes hyper is also important for
taking the fight to the zombies in
gardens and graveyards if you can find
that teleporter and keep them from
building it you'll force them to waste
precious time shambling from their spawn
point use Hyper with frequent jumps to
make it hard for your enemies to track
you and then lay waste to any engineers
that come within range as for rooting
down as a Gatling peashooter you'll want
to reserve that for long ish distances
and for shutting down routes commonly
walked by the dead
healing peashooters is a noble goal for
sunflowers and the heal beam has a
really quick cool down so you can pretty
much use it whenever you need it and
don't forget that sunflowers can use
their primary weapon while heal beaming
to support the team's organic offensive
just don't get too cocky and put
yourself out on the frontlines because
you are a fairly delicate little
sunflower hanging back a bit we'll also
position you well for reviving allies
which you can do extra quickly and which
is super important for your defensive
efforts and super mega important in team
vanquish where each revive is a point
stolen from the zambese if the shambling
horrors are still at a distance though
go ahead and pot yourself and beam happy
sunshine rays of death right into their
undead eyeballs throw down a heal flower
to increase your longevity and it's cute
and like you know pretty helpful also
last but not least the weirdest weed in
the bunch the chopper with no projectile
weapon and a penchant for jean paree
it's a whole different game when you
play the purple plant you can take out
any zombie player with a single chomp
provided you sneak up behind them and
see that red target appear on them this
gets easier if you burrow as zombies
might not see you or might not be able
to maneuver away fast enough and if you
burrow and remain absolutely still
you'll be completely undetectable until
the moment of cheong this toothy
salivating swallow is one of the most
satisfying moves in the game but it
leaves you vulnerable because it takes
time to choke down all that festering
flesh if you can slow nearby enemies
with coop before you chomp you stand a
better chance of survival and laying
down spiked weed traps as you flee is a
good way to hinder your pursuers as long
as you save a spiked weed for desperate
escapes you should feel free to throw
them down as often as you can properly
timed abilities can be a big difference
maker but unused abilities are like so
many unsewn seeds never to bear fruit
Destin's to be eaten by birds somehow
most plants are better at range so keep
your distance and coordinate your firing
lines stick with your teammates revive
your teammates and celebrate victory by
dancing with your teammates plant power
you